we now develop a methodology for finding
the PDF of the sum of two independent
random variables when these random
variables are continuous with known PDFs
so in that case Z will also be
continuous and so we'll have a PDF the
development is quite analogous to the
one for the discrete case and in the
discrete case we obtained this
convolution formula this convolution
formula corresponds to a summation over
all ways that a certain sum can be
realized in this picture these are all
the ways that the sum of three can be
realized in the continuous case the
different ways that the constant sum can
be realized corresponds to a line so
this is a line in which X plus y is
equal to a constant and we need to
somehow add over all the possible ways
that the sum can be obtained ad over all
the points on this line now when were
summing over all the points of the line
we really need to employ an integral and
this leads to the following yes for the
formula instead of having a summation we
will have an integral and the integral
is overall the X Y pairs whose sum is a
constant number little Z so we have here
the familiar recipe that sums are
replaced by integrals and pmfs are
replaced by PDFs so this formula is
entirely plausible and it is called the
continuous convolution formula what we
want to do next is to actually justify
this formula more rigorously we will use
the following trick we will first
conditioned on the random variable X
taking on a specific value if we do this
conditioning then the random variable Z
becomes little X plus y and to make the
argument more transparent we're going to
look first at the special case where
little X
let's say the number three in which case
our random variable Z is equal to y plus
three let us now calculate the
conditional PDF of Z in a universe in
which we are told that the random
variable X takes on the value of 3
now given that X takes on the value of 3
the random variable Z is the same as the
random variable Y plus 3 and now we have
the conditional PDF of Y plus 3 given X
however we have assumed that X and y are
independent so the conditional PDF is
going to be the same as the
unconditional PDF of Y plus 3 and we
obtain this expression now what is this
we know the PDF of Y but now we want the
PDF of Y plus 3 which is a simple
version of a linear function of a single
random variable Y for a linear function
of this form we have already derived a
formula in the notation we have used in
the past if we have a random variable X
and we add a constant to it the PDF of
the new random variable is the PDF of X
but shifted by an amount equal to B to
the right and that's what this shifting
corresponds to mathematically now let us
apply this formula to the case that we
have here we need to keep track of the
different symbols so capital y
corresponds to X B corresponds to 3
little X corresponds to Z and by using
these correspondences what we obtain is
f sub y of this argument which is Z in
our case minus B which is 3 in our key
and this is the final form for the
conditional density of Z given that X
takes a specific value it's nothing more
than the density of Y but shifted by 3
units to the right
let us now generalize this instead of
using X equal to 3 let us use a general
number and this gives us the more
general formula that the conditional PDF
of Z given that X takes on a specific
value is equal to just use little X here
instead of 3 it takes this form so we do
have now in our hand the formula for the
conditional density of Z given X since
we have the conditional and we also know
the PDF of X we can use the
multiplication rule to find the joint
PDF of X and Z by the multiplication
rule it is the marginal PDF of x times
the conditional PDF of Z given X which
in our case takes this particular form
and now that we have the joint PDF in
our hands we can use another familiar
formula that takes us from the joint to
the marginal if we take the joint PDF
and integrate with respect to one
arguments we obtain the marginal PDF of
the other random variable using this
specific form that we have for the joint
PDF in this formula we have finally
obtained this expression this is the
integral of the joint PDF of X with Z
integrated over all X's and this proves
this convolution formula in terms of the
mechanics of carrying out the
calculation of the convolution the
mechanics are exactly the same as in the
discrete case if you want to solve a
problem graphically what you will do is
to take the PDF of Y flip it
horizontally
and then shifted by an amount of little
Z cross multiply
terms and integrate them out